do the hillary  [Music]  do the hillary throw your head from side  to side can we collapse you and me do  the hillary shake your hands like you  got parkinson's nothing to see here just  plank the allergies  do the hillary  do the hillary  do the hillary  do the hillary throw your head from side  to side then we collapse you and me do  the hillary  [Music]  do the hillary  hillary rodham clinton down i thought it  was pneumonia  this week i thought it was pneumonia  that you had  it was it was pneumonia it was totally  pneumonia  so you just misspoke well you know as  well as i do stephen that allergies  typically leads to pneumonia no i don't  know that i don't think anymore epilepsy  or parkinson's or the like now did you  say parkinson's it sounded like you said  parkinson's